[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol
of choice i'm dave ramsey your host
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best selling author of the book
debt-free
degree and host of the ever-popular
youtube show the table is my co-host
today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five the advice is free
the call is free and some say it's worth
exactly
what you pay for it matthew is in
valdosta georgia hey matthew how are you
hi good man how can we help
i was calling today to see what to do
with my mobile home
my question is i have it i'm working on
getting it paid off so i want to know
would it be better just to
pay the extra and pay it off and maybe
keep it as a rental property
or pay it down sell it
and put it down on a new home
[Music]
is there another options where you can
just sell it today
i mean i can but i still got to pay it
down a little bit because i'm a little
upside down in it
uh okay okay what's it worth what's it
worth today
right around 50 000 is what i had it
valued as
how much do you owe 53
yeah what would it be worth in uh 10
years
no i'm not real sure maybe
40 20 10 20 maybe 10
yeah so investments should go up
mobile homes go down i got you they're
not investments
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do what anthony was suggesting
suggesting and that is get out of it
sooner rather than later
uh for simply that reason because you're
getting ready to turn over a period of
number of years we don't know the exact
number but you're getting ready to turn
50 000 into 10
000. and uh we can't do that very often
and become wealthy
yeah so you when you want a rental
property you want a rental property
that's going up in value
while you're dealing with renters and
collecting rent
yeah you don't want a rental property
that's going down in values and all you
get
is rent because you're you know
systematically the asset
is yeah it's appreciating it's going
away
yeah so what i would do is i'll just get
i'll go ahead and just
put it on the market and just cover the
difference you know if it's three
thousand dollars on a difference i
rather you pay three thousand dollars
today
then thirteen thousand dollars in the
next year or two you know because while
you're trying to pay it off it's
depreciating so you're gonna always be
playing that game
you're chasing it is that just like a
car yeah i mean cars go down in value
that's how you get upside down on a car
yeah and uh you know you can't no one
can look at you with a straight face and
call a car an investment
it's a consumption item yeah uh and you
know they go down in value
like a rock that's where chevy gets at
and you ford people aren't any better
it's found on the road depreciated right
and so it's gonna they all go down in
value there's no exceptions i mean
the only exception would be a classic
car that you don't drive that's a
collectible
and you might buy something that goes up
in value i like watching those car
auctions of those
200 000 cars from the 70s that i bought
for
3 000 and didn't keep so there you go
but that's not
that's that is not the normal situation
with the vehicle the normal situation
with the vehicle is
that you're going to lose your butt yeah
and the same thing would be true of a
mobile home
uh the difference is with a mobile home
you actually have a different option
which is buy something that goes up in
value yes
uh the old house thing and uh
and then you've done pretty well on your
real estate i have i've done
very well you're happy your timing is
my pocketbook is screaming happy that's
all your timing is
ramsey-ask hey listen i mean i'm
connected to the mr real estate guy so
everyone thinks he's the only get out of
that guy man listen i'll listen no
cause i tell you i i don't sell stuff i
just buy it and you sell it
i do you take the cash off the table i
sure do
no wait linda
is in san jose california hi linda how
are you
hi there thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
i have to i have two options so option
number one
is do i do a cash out refinance on my
property
to use that money to build a home in a
lower expense
state option number two is i can
liquidate my brokerage account
which currently giving me roughly
between 16 to 18
rate of return on my money and use that
money
to um to pay for the construction of the
house
is there an option
sell sell the house that you are going
to refinance and cash out
and use that money to build the property
oh man
i've been around well i was going to do
that but option 3 can't be there because
we currently have a business
and our children are still in college
and we
and why do you need a house in another
state yeah
well that is going to be my retirement
property okay when you get ready to
retire then sell the house you're in and
move over there
but you don't need to buy a house 10
years before you retire because someday
you're going to need it
yeah okay okay
well you are not going to do this she's
not she's not going to do this
so the reason i brought up about the
cash out refinance is because my
property is worth 2 million
and i only owe 200 000 on it so if i do
refinance and get the money out how much
is in your brokerage account
uh roughly 300 000. okay i'll probably
just pay off your house out of your
brokerage account
and be debt free and then let's go let's
just build a big pile of wealth over
here to the side
and when you get ready to leave sell the
two million dollar house which by then
will be worth more
and use some of your brokerage money or
whatever you need to do at that time
but you don't need to build a house that
you don't need
you don't need this other house well
what we've been doing is
we would like to have a property up
there where my husband and i can
work there three days a week and then
come back to california four days a week
and that's what we're thinking because i
need to get my husband
somewhat away from this area where we
are it's very congested and i
want him to relax a little bit that was
my thought
if it's just more than just money so
what does the uh
what is the property going to cost that
you're going to build that you're going
to live in halftime
we already paid the land as debt free
how much money do you need to complete
this deal
roughly 300 000. okay i would use your
brokerage money then yeah
well listen listen you called the ramsey
show
100 of the time we don't tell you to
borrow money yeah
100 of the time i would never tell you
to cash out to buy a second home
yeah to refinance cash out on your
personal residence it means you can't
afford the second home
and i i would i would disagree with
showing the last part dave i'm gonna say
still pay off your house and then just
stack up the money for a year or two and
then go buy the other house
that'd be okay too you know um but if
you're gonna do the other house deal
yeah you know what i would do that
you're right because i wouldn't listen
the second house is a toy exactly your
husband needs to relax
buy a vacation thank you dave
thank you yeah you don't buy a second
home which is a toy
until your present residence is paid off
and until you pay cash for your second
home you got me on that
i thank you dave i was about to let you
go after that comment
let me go where i ain't going anywhere
let me go set me free
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five real estate's going crazy
we were just talking about that and peak
real estate season is here
this year things are different prices
are higher competition between buyers is
intense sellers need to know what
they're doing if they're going to make
the most
out of the sale of their home right now
you can make a six figure mistake
messing this up a friend of ours anthony
works on the team here sold his house
the other day
150 000 over asking
17 bids wow
what in the world do you make a big
mistake if you don't have a
i mean this is not amateur hour you need
a real estate agent that
has played this game before so you want
to high octane high protein
real estate so good stuff you got to get
her done
and get with one of our endorsed local
providers the real estate agents we
trust our elps will help guide you
through the entire
home buying or home selling process
ramsey solutions dot com slash agent
will connect you up with our trusted
elp our ramsey trusted real estate
agents ramsey solutions
dot or ramsay solutions.com
agent check it out all right dallas is
with us dallas
is in san antonio that's so confusing
hey dallas how are you
good how are you how are you gentlemen
doing better than i deserve what's up
so um my wife recently changed jobs and
she had about
forty thousand dollars in the uh 401k
at her old job and we're looking at um
where to put that um where to put that
money
good and her new new job it's a
they have a 401k but they don't match
and i know from listening to you that we
should make the
put the money somewhere where we can
choose how to manage it instead of
someone else
good so um i have i have an
uh my own roth ira account with charles
schwab and i was just wondering
if you'd recommend like putting it in
the same spot or if it'd be somewhere
better for us to hold that money into
for now
well schwab is fine uh obviously you're
self-managing all of that
and so i personally use one of our smart
buster pros
because i can get some insight from
people who are playing in the stuff all
day long i can pick up the phone and
call the guy
and i know a ton obviously about mutual
funds i've got millions
tens of millions of dollars invested in
mutual funds but uh but i also love
having a guy in my corner
that messes in it all day long his he
just eats breathes and sleeps mutual
funds that's what he does all day
and i can pick up the phone he's a
friend if i die my wife is going to call
him and say you know where's our stuff
and so this is what i want in my corner
for my investment person
versus a kind of a diy thing so
but schwab is fine if you want to just
diy it but if you want to get a little
bit more
pull all your accounts in one place
begin to develop a long-term
wealth-building relationship with an
advisor you can click smart investor at
dave
ramseysolutions.com and uh
find someone in your area it's good to
have somebody in your corner no
absolutely dave i have one person in my
corner too and i'm always asking them
little questions here and they're
learning um you know but uh absolutely
smart vested pros way to go yeah and
just we're always gonna tell you as you
said you had that figured out dallas
that we're gonna
always when you leave your company roll
your 401k
to a traditional ira there's no taxes on
that direct transfer
rollover and uh uh my personal
investments and the investments we've
told people to do for
for 40 years or this 30 years are the
same
and it's four types of mutual funds
growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international and
in each of those categories pick a fund
that has outperformed its category
the index for its category and you can
find funds that have outperformed the
market
not all of them have but you can find
them with a good with guidance from
somebody like a smartvestor pro
luke is with us luke is in owensboro hi
luke how are you
hey dave doing great how are you better
than i deserve what's up
hey um so anyways right now i'm working
on
coming up with a counteroffer the state
of kentucky is widening the road in
front of my duplex
and they need most of the land and most
of the duplex
so anyways i'm trying to come up with
the best option after we
get through this negotiation for
reinvesting the money
i recently found out about the 1033
litecoin exchange
and i was curious if you think i would
be able to use that since there is like
a threat of imminent domain here
is that rev the difference in a 1031 and
a 1033 eminent domain
yeah it says eminent domain or the
threat of eminent domain
that's definitely what this is i mean
they're taking it you didn't have an
option here
correct yeah i wanted to keep it to
retirement i'm currently 34.
so i've never heard of a 33 that's a
1033 i know what a 1031 is but a 1033 is
the same thing as a 1031
except its imminent domain what's the
what's the difference other than that
so basically um you have two two to
three years to reinvest the money and
you get to hold on to instead of putting
it in like a third party account
is what i'm saying so that would be much
better deal especially
with the way the housing market is right
now yeah
reinvest but a good time to cash out
assuming they pay you market value so
uh well what i want to do because i
don't know anything about this
uh and i've and i've you know been in
real estate my whole life
i'm i'm it's a wonderful thing i'm just
learning something brand new
i'm excited about that but if i'm in
your shoes since i don't know
i'm going to not depend on a website
to inform me and me end up getting
tagged with taxes i want to get a good
tax professional local that i can get my
hands around his or her neck
and choke them if they're wrong because
i really want somebody digging into this
that knows their stuff
yeah definitely yeah this probably
doesn't happen too often it's just some
kind of predicament i found myself then
yeah but i mean how'd you figure out
that you're just doing some research on
google or what
yeah i just started googling and kind of
went down the rabbit hole and
found out about that and other people
i've talked to have heard of it but i
don't know if anybody has ever done it
yeah so the thing is yeah the 1031
is a fairly standard process but you
don't want to miss a step on that or the
whole all the taxes come due
and i suspect the 1033 is the same way
and so if some goo
wrote a blog on the internet about it
and you go by that but that's not
aligned with actual
the detailed nuance of tax law you could
screw this up and
and bring all these taxes due and defeat
the whole purpose so you really want to
make sure you've got
every little thing every t crossed every
i dotted
every jot and tittle uh is taken care of
because that um that would that would be
the part that would scare me because i
don't know how to do this i would want
to really have a pro in my corner
and it's worth the couple of hundred
dollars fee
to have a a tax professional look over
it guide you through the process
because you're going to save more than
that on taxes by doing this the last
thing i'll tell you is this the state
the city the government institution
sometimes they get bureaucratic
and they don't really have many emotions
in the deal but they uh they
they make they make a wrong offer and so
if you can
support with comparable sales
a market value that is higher than they
are offering you
i'm going to hold their feet to the fire
for full market value
in this market uh not not a year ago
but today as hot as real estate is today
they're taking a property you didn't
want to sell
and they eminent domain requires full
market value or we go to court and the
judge looks at my comparable sales
and my appraisal and says oh it doesn't
agree with the
bureaucrat of the state now you can't
just make up something you can't go well
i think it's worth that that doesn't
matter
i'm saying actual appraisal technique
with comparable sales make sure you're
getting every dime
you're due so now dave let me ask this
question because i'm learning
uh this is brand new to me to 1033 as
well
with it being the state saying hey we
need your house
to for us to make these roads better
shouldn't he get assistance with the
taxes then since he has no say-so
because it's state versus federal
federal tax is where your capital gain
is and and the feds don't give a real
yes how you got the money but the 1033
allows him to get paid
use that money to buy another property
and roll his old basis into the new
property
thereby all the gain and there's no tax
on the game
got you so it's almost like the call
before with the ira rollover yes
it works like a rollover in that sense
that's the way it works that's a 1031.
the 33 evidently got some nuances to it
because it's forced by the government
meaning imminent domain okay
this is the ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jonathan is with us hey jonathan what's
up
nothing much dave super excited to be
here how are you honored to have you man
where do you live
i live in west lafayette indiana oh cool
and all the way to nashville to do a
dead free screen how much did you pay
off
i paid off seventy three thousand seven
hundred and twenty eight dollars
love it how long did this take you took
me 18 months or about a year and a half
good for you and your range of income
during that year and a half
i started at about 66 000 and ended at
about 80 000.
what do you do i'm a quality engineer at
a local automotive plant
good for you okay what kind of debt was
your 74 thousand
46 thousand 000 of it was student loan
debt
and 25 000 a car loan
and 2 000 uh consumer debt
credit cards for some electronics you
know aren't you okay how old are you
electronics electronics electronics
they're expensive
uh 26 years old okay 20. so what
happened a year and a half ago
um i never had a great relationship with
money
i was always a very big spender
buying things i didn't really need
trying to keep up with the joneses so to
speak
i remember at my first job out of
college there was this group of guys who
all drove corvettes
so good idea here have my first car
out of college be a 2003 c5 corvette
of course yeah there you go because that
always happens yeah
very normal um they say it uh
it pays to look good and i was paying i
think it was a five-year note with the
seven percent interest rate
wow i thought those guys at the
dealership were being really nice to me
yeah they were they they helped you get
that car you wanted yeah
that's funny i started a a new job and
there was this group of guys there who
were always talking about dave ramsey
dave ramsey
and you know i'm not one to really take
a lot of
uh referrals for the podcast to listen
to
um but they said something they said
if only i heard about dave ramsey when i
was your age i'd be a millionaire right
now
so my my interest was peaked how do i
become a millionaire
yeah so greg my co-worker lent me your
total money makeover book
and i'm also not much of a reader big
spender not a big reader
and i read that book faster than i've
read any other book
finished in about a week and
it really appealed to my logical side i
saw some of the errors in my ways
did everything wrong that i'm not
supposed to do
money-wise and really got me thinking
about
you know my why and all the good reasons
to get out of debt
yeah what was your why i'm curious your
main why uh
to be honest with you i took a trip to
hawaii
one uh one summer i said this is you
know such a beautiful place
uh i would love to retire here oh
but i know that's not just gonna fall in
my lap so that's gonna take a lot of
hard work and discipline and
also uh you know
growing up we never really like owned
the house we lived in it was always
mortgaged
with the plan of all always moving away
so
you know having those roots building a
strong a foundation with family
is something that's always really pushed
me through i love it i do love it 26
years old making six to six thousand
dollars a year
uh you paid off 73 000 in a year and a
half this means that you were really
making some strong sacrifices
uh you was you were living way below
your means throughout these last
18 months what was the hardest thing
about that journey
um i i think the hardest thing was
taking a bonus check
i got and putting everything towards the
debt
um right in the beginning i i got this
20
000 bonus check and i hadn't even
started baby step one
and so putting 19 000 of it
straight to the debt was really really
daunting well that that was
commitment though that's when you knew
it was game on right it was
yeah yeah you were not fooling around
anymore this is we're doing this this is
a whole new thing
yeah way to go man yeah that that's when
the uh
you know when the everything's a theory
till you get hit in the mouth you know
and uh that old saying you know and
and that's the truth here i mean
everything's a theory to you drop
19 000 and it's all gone
yeah yeah because you had to clear up
the debt because you'd already spent the
money before you got it yeah wow way to
go man
yeah way to go so who were your biggest
cheerleaders
uh obviously my girlfriend athena
she really pushed me to um
be debt free she's debt-free herself and
uh
wanting to you know get married one day
and start
have a good foundation um
as well as my co-workers uh greg
patrick ray steve they were all very
encouraging
always checking up on me well how's your
debt-free journey going
all the guys that wanted you to show you
how to be a millionaire yes that's the
one yeah
i like these guys it's a good group man
you become who you hang around with so i
think you chose well
yes very good very good so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
first and foremost know your why i think
in this journey i was
i was learning so much about the
benefits of being debt-free trying to
share this with my friends but they
weren't really on board
and i think it's because you can't just
convince someone with the benefits you
got to feel it in your heart and
and it's got to become a part of your
mission so knowing your why and
second the budgeting it's
it's really like what i've heard on the
podcast before money just comes out of
nowhere
and with the every dollar app i used
that's how it was
i actually calculated it would take me
24 months
to get out of debt but with the
budgeting money just started coming out
of
yeah everywhere well you increased your
income 14 000
during this time absolutely well you're
taking on overtime or sidekicks
uh overtime yeah okay yeah and so hey
money is available i'm gonna go get some
there you go baby
ding ding yeah that's that that's
fabulous i'm so proud of you man i am
well done what's next i'm curious now
since you're debt-free
what's on the next uh thing for you um
saving up for a house okay
i'd love to uh have the goal of paying
cash for a house
i've always heard it on the podcast it's
a
shooting for the moon but no it's not no
no it's not you
you can make 80 grand you know and you
don't have any payments i mean how does
it feel to have no payments i know man
you're 26.
it's scary honestly scary what was the
one thing that when you paid it off
the one debt and you went god i hate you
people i'm so glad you're gone which one
was that
i would say your name i would say it was
the car loan yeah
i would drive the car and be really uh
do you keep the car and paid it off
oh yeah yeah so you still got the vat no
no no no no that one's oh that one was
gone
that was gone okay so what kind of car
uh it's a chevy bolt
okay so when that's gone when that debt
was gone that's that's the big one yeah
i love it i i got a picture on youtube
here i own the title to my car there we
go good
that's a fun feeling man so there it is
well done well done we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in your story to move on to that
millionaire status you are heading that
direction man and
you'll be on our millionaire theme hour
before you know it our everyday or baby
steps
millionaires way to go and of course
another copy of the total money makeover
for you to give to someone
and maybe it'll be the first book they
read in a while and uh they'll stay up
all night and read it and
it'll change their whole direction like
it did for you i'm so proud of you thank
you
very very well done jonathan from uh
west
lafayette is that louisiana indiana
indiana indiana okay cool
74 thousand dollars paid off in 18
months making 66 to 80.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
hey man going along from clueless send
us some guys that say you can be a
millionaire
here's the book here's the posh under
some guys that say you can be a
millionaire
here's the book here's the podcast ding
ding walk the baby steps here we are i
love it look at it
so proud of you jonathan well done this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
brittany is in knoxville hi brittany how
are you
i'm doing well how are y'all better than
we deserve what's up
so i am on baby steps 3d saving for a
down payment on our house
um i'm currently a nurse that i work
monday through friday so i'm trying to
figure out a side hustle where i can
make some extra money to eventually pay
off the house early
and i'm wondering if it would be a good
idea for me to start a
photography business on the side
are you any good at photography
i've not really had much practice and
currently i don't
actually have a camera i've been wanting
to play around with my moms
a little bit but so why photography then
i i've always liked
photography itself i like the idea of
helping families make memories that sort
of thing
and i know when we took my senior
pictures with my aunt uh just
coming up with poses and stuff i had a
lot of fun with that
okay and your mom's camera is what what
is it is it a good enough camera to take
some pictures with to get started
i'm not sure it i think she got it in
like 2013
so it's a with a decent camera then but
it's pretty outdated i would also
definitely need a laptop because my
laptop from college is shot
it doesn't really work anymore yeah and
is your goal brittany to
generate extra income or are you trying
to start uh
extra income to pay off debt are you
trying to get extra income
to you know just because you want to
have another hobby a side business
i would like to um
like i said i'm on babysit 3b so i want
to save up for down payment and then
my goal is to eventually i'm 23.
uh i'm single i want to have a paid for
house by the time i have kids eventually
good so what do you mean so i can stay
home yeah
what do you make i make about 55 000 and
what do you want to spend on a camera
and laptop
uh it would be probably for that and
like some sd cards and stuff my budget
would be two thousand
okay and so if you take two thousand
dollars in the middle of the table and
and light it on fire for a hobby it does
not keep you from hitting your goals
okay and so that's like your worst case
scenario
in other words you buy these things and
it never amounts to squat you don't make
any money
but you got a nice camera and you got a
nice laptop and you just did this for a
hobby
and you spent some of your house money
to do that or some of your income money
to do that
you see what i'm saying yes now if you
told me it's 20 000 i would say no
right yeah right because as a ratio in
your world that's two stinking much
money to burn
yeah if you make 500 000 a year and you
want to burn
20 000 we'll talk about it but you see
what i'm doing
i mean we're just saying does this keep
you
from hitting your goals by the time
you're 30 no it does not
and so it's okay it's okay at that
budget amount to give this a try
um i i will tell you that
um from a business only perspective what
i think you got to do is you ought to
check out uh christy wright and business
boutique oh just about to say
and begin to think about how we're
looking at this um
this sounds like something you you
thought about over coffee and prayer one
morning and you've actually never done
it at all and all of a sudden now you're
opening a business doing it
that's a that's a bit of a leap yeah and
so i would rather you
um you know before we actually set up
shop i'd rather just go around and
get some confirmation from people that
you actually have an eye
through that lens to and some people go
wow i really like those shots
and maybe somebody would pay for that
you know or you know or people go
yeah maybe you shouldn't do this
and do some research on it too um you
know youtube is very good uh
if you're gonna buy a camera i would
definitely jump on youtube
and see what's the best camera out there
in your budget people are doing reviews
all the time
set your budget and it'd be very clear
and then you say hey
best camera under 500 bucks you're going
to find a lot of cameras
uh that people are saying here's here
here's the good things but
i definitely would say sit back and ask
yourself
you know uh am i doing this because i
really want to become a photographer
or am i doing this just because and if
you're trying to save money to buy a
house you can go drive for uber
you know if it's a temporary fix because
i don't see you making a lot of money
that quick
on something you've never done before
but if you pick up an uber job a
delivering pizza delivering groceries
picking up people groceries you can make
money
instantly so i think i don't know yeah i
i kind of had the feeling this is i
agree with you but
i kind of the where i went on it was
it's more about scratching an itch than
it was actually
i got you didn't make your money i got
you and so it's quasi-hobby that might
turn into some money
i got you and i if that's the case if if
it does turn into money we'll call that
wonderful
yes you know but uh you know what's it
how many pictures you gotta take to get
your two thousand dollars back
a lot yeah depending on me as a beginner
photographer a lot and a lot of time
because you know she got to get her
skills up yeah
jean is with us jeans in cincinnati hi
gene how are you
i'm well how are you great how can we
help
great it's wonderful to talk to you and
i appreciate having access to someone
with
wisdom and getting some great advice so
i have
i have a son daughter-in-law four
grandkids
and um a number of years ago um i paid
for my son and daughter-in-law to go
through dave ramsey and
financial peace university that's right
okay
and they even taught it at their church
but they are very good listed they're
not living
and the four children have not been
taught dave ramsey
and they are two are teenagers
and two are over 18.
and so um
i'm seeing lots of issues and
talking isn't going anywhere what i need
is some
i want my grandkids to learn dave ramsey
and so i want to compel them
and have rewards along the way to have
them do it
do the steps so i need some
wisdom on your part on how to compel
them um
to take dave ramsey without being pushy
about it um having
rewards along the way as i said and
measurable
and so if you could give me some advice
on how to do that i would appreciate it
what a wonderful heart you have to love
your grandkids
um and i i i
i one of the i i told someone my friends
the other day
and and my kids all are you know they're
not off the rails they're on track
obviously i'm real proud of them
but even in that case they just do some
things different than i would obviously
and i think the most difficult stage of
parenting is when you're not allowed to
tell them what to do anymore because
they grew up
that's right and you have to watch them
do stupid butt stuff
and it's aggravating even if it's
something minor
you know and it just aggravates you and
um
so it's i think it's the hardest thing
is the control
so let me just tell you what you just
said as an example because i was
laughing to myself because it sounded
like something i would do
because i'm going to make fun of you
because i would do it too okay you said
how can i compel them without being
pushy
the definition of compel is pushy okay
you want to grab them up by the scruff
of the neck and make them freaking
behave
is what you want to do grandma i know
you you're just like me
yep you're absolutely right yeah and you
can't
because they're grown and they're not
yours i know
so here here's what i have to do i have
to
periodically and my friends that are my
age and your age
facing these same exact things i have to
periodically
stop breathe
you know you remember the old thing when
they catch on fire stop drop and roll
you remember that it's kind of like that
okay i have to stop
i have to breathe and i have to go i
cannot
talk to them like they're kin to me
i have to talk to them like they're my
friend
or even my friend's kid who i have no
ability to compel to do anything
instead my only shot at moving them
along
is persuasion okay
that's your only shot grandma persuasion
and so you just sit down and take them
to breakfast and you say i love you more
than life itself
and i've learned some stuff and i
wouldn't bring up dave ramsey i think
i'd leave dave ramsey out of this
i would just say common sense and say
i've learned some stuff
and because i love you i'd love for you
to know that stuff can i talk you into
walking through it with me
because i love you so much that's
compassion
and persuasion you're not going to
compel anybody it's grown to do anything
they don't do it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us anthony o'neil ramsey
personality number one
best-selling author of the book debt
free degree
and host of the ever-popular youtube
phenomenon called the table
where they sit at the table he and his
guests and discuss
things going on in the world including
your money your life including how to be
successful
and it's uh vastly popular so be sure
and join him on
youtube and uh be sure and join him
today and ask your question the phone
number triple eight
eight two five five two two five josh
is with us josh is in san antonio hi
josh how are you i'm doing well dave how
are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up so i'm a
realtor with the crisis of conscience
uh realtor i also teach financial peace
i'm currently teaching my third class
and the thing i've come across
especially in these crazy times is
what do you do when you got these people
that the lender's like oh you gotta go
get a credit card oh you gotta go do
this debt
i told people look there's other ways to
do this
and i've lost business you know and
that's fine god's taking care of my
family but
how do you approach this as a real
estate guy you've been this forever
you know doing both sides you know
you're talking about the
do you go get a credit card to build
your credit thing is that what you're
talking about
yes sir okay then what you have to have
is you
you need to find how much volume do you
do how many houses a year do you sell
uh i do about about two million a year
um
it's long story how my my stuff floats
you know my family is
we've been debt-free for a while so
we're not having to go up and get every
single deal and just do whatever i try
to do mine
is biblically as possible which is kind
of hard to do sometimes
for sure sure yeah well i and i think
that
you know what we had to do uh in the
instance uh
20 plus years ago 25 years ago with
churchill mortgage was mike hardwick and
i had to sit down and say listen if i'm
going to send folks to churchill
mortgage
uh and tell people that i never say
anything more than a 15-year fixed rate
where the payment is more than a fourth
of your take-home pay
and you need to be prepared to do manual
underwriting because
a lot of the people that do what i teach
are not going to have a credit score
and so you can't tell people to go get a
credit card when i just when the lead i
sent you just went through financial
peace university and i told them cut up
their credit cards
so we can't be it's inconsistent and
people get pissed off when you're
inconsistent because it feels like a
lack of integrity
um and so these are the discussions mike
and i had 25 years ago
and we've had him a few times since then
over the years as he's grown and
he you know he buys another comp another
mortgage company another city and he has
to teach them
you know the our way of looking at
things because if i send leads over
there they get mad
you know yeah and you got the same thing
it's not just a crisis of confidence
it's it's
a conscience but it's a they're they're
looking at us like we
like we lied or something you know and
so um
uh you know what i would tell you to do
is begin to develop just on a local
level a relationship with a mortgage
broker a mortgage company that um
or maybe just an underwriter at one of
the companies or or a
uh you know a loan originator that's
just got
you know they they get it they you know
they go through financial peace
university maybe you pay for it or
whatever
yeah uh and and so that you can get
aligned on
when i send a customer over there i you
know i
i don't want to hear that you told him
to go get a credit card
right or i can't send you that business
yeah
you know and so um you know because i
can't it's inconsistent
and and it you know it's um
it it you know standard operating
procedure in the mortgage business won't
work for me
and it won't work for you josh now
you're not saying i have trouble telling
them to get a mortgage because you know
that
we all while we believe the best thing
is the 100 down plan we
calm down a little bit and allow a 15
year in our guidelines
knowing that with the idea though that
they're going to get it paid off soon
right
correct yeah yeah so that's not your
that's not your crisis
you know and i've actually had to walk
away from business in the past two years
i've probably walked away from about a
million and a half in volume just
because
it wasn't going to be a good fit and i
didn't want to be the realtor they look
back on going
it's your fault i did this deal i don't
care about that yeah
you just have to somehow you have to
position yourself in the customer's mind
that you're coaching them not just
selling them a house
correct okay and i think and when when
you got a customer that's crazy and they
won't allow that
then they're not a customer exactly let
them go let them go
and then just leave with your heart man
you know just leave with your heart
lead with the coaching lead with the
guidance and i think that will honestly
eventually earn you
more volume because i love
my real estate agent who's part of our
program
and as a guy who teaches it he's always
holding me accountable hey anthony
did you check your budget is that less
than 25
you know and i love that because i know
his heart is in the right place
uh so i would just say just leave with
your heart lead with the guidance lead
with the coaching
and i believe eventually it will bring
you more guidance
down the road not guidance but more
volume yeah i mean god's going to bless
the
intent of your heart here that's what it
amounts to so i think the thing you
want to be careful of and in my seat i
have to be careful of it as well
is to be persuasive and winsome
not legalistic yes and be persuasive on
the principles
and say this is why yeah you know listen
man you're acting like you're gonna like
you you're gonna get alone here
you're not gonna be able to breathe and
i'm worried about you yeah
you know i think it's gonna leave you in
a bad place and i think you got a little
bit of house fever i think you need to
go
take a cold shower we need to rethink
you know if i was your older brother if
i was your dad
you know i would tell you a son don't do
this and so i'm going to do that because
i care about you
and um and if you want if you're
hell-bent on driving your car off the
cliff you're gonna do it by yourself
because i'm not gonna participate in
that dave but if it what you just said
is 10 times better than a
regular guy who's trying to get his
three percent oh yeah do whatever you
want to do let me just get the money
yeah you know that well but not you know
when somebody's got house fever
yeah and they're hell-bent on doing
something stupid but and getting a loan
that's
55 of their take-home pay which they can
get approved for
on an adjustable rate mortgage that's
gonna
ding them in a year and a half right
because it starts in the hole on the
index and they're going to come out
they're going to come out at 55
they're going to be looking at 63 the
next year and
you know they're just hell-bent on
self-destruction because they got the
fever and they need that jacuzzi with a
skylight
and you can't stop stupid when it's on
when it's on a you know train
track heading down the heading off the
cliff and so
you know all you can do is get out of
the way and just you know wave the cape
and go olay
you know and just good luck with this
you know because i've tried to stop
stupid and my own friends you have too
yes
yes and they look at you with one eye
yeah you know and the other eye is
looking off somewhere else
it's weird yeah it's like they're
possessed and then when they do the
stupid
and they realize it's stupid they didn't
want to come back and apologize for the
stupidity i'm like no don't apologize
now
yeah you didn't hurt me no
it was you i was trying to save you yeah
i'm not stupid not
as much as i used to be right
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at backslash
budget we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host
today you can join us here at triple
eight eight two five
five two here at ramsey solutions we're
on a mission to transform
so many lives the disruption in this
toxic culture spreads like wildfire
what's that mean
i mean it means imagine a world where
it's weird to have a student loan
instead everybody has one imagine a
world where it's normal to pay cash for
your car or even your house where
the credit card is looked at as the
cigarette of the financial world
now imagine being part of our team
that's on a mission
to make all of that a reality
and you're working at it every day work
that matters helping actually helping
people
we've got just under a thousand folks
working on our team 996
this week to create digital products
services that transform people's lives
our goal
is to disrupt this toxic culture
whether it's career whether it's mental
health whether it's money whatever it is
success if you want to join us on this
crusade we're on the hunt for software
engineers with expertise in ruby on
rails
java c-sharp front-end technologies
if you're a ux designer seo and content
marketing specialist we'd love to talk
to you and we've got about
300 positions total not all of them
technology
that are available and we're going to
hire this year
so find out about all of it by texting
work 233 789
text work to 33789
and you can find out about the
opportunities to join us here at ramsey
we would love to have you
d'artagnan is with us and he is in
kansas hey darth anion what's up
hi ramsay it's great to talk to you you
too how can we help
so i'm currently in my penultimate
semester of college in this fall i
anticipate i'll have to pay between
1500 and three thousand dollars out of
pocket i have a nine thousand dollar
card note that uh that i wanna get rid
of and i recently got rid of investments
that i had because
after listening to you i realized i
shouldn't have investments when i'm in
debt
so how should i distribute this eight
thousand dollars of investments that
i've recently just acquired into my bank
account
with between like uh living paying off
my car
and then the anticipated money i'll have
to spend for tuition this fall
for my last semester so you have one
semester i'm currently in my second
class this summer
and then in the fall i'll be in my last
okay and that's total of three thousand
dollars
from if i heard you correctly for
tuition yes
that i have remaining that i'll have to
pay out of pocket all right how are you
eating what are you doing for rent food
and so forth
uh for for rent in the fall i'll be
paying about
350 dollars total split between my
girlfriend and i so
i'll be paying 30 350 myself and then
i spend about five 150 on food
each month because i eat beans and rice
pretty much how are you paying for all
that
i have a job uh so i live in i live in
kansas city but i go to school and then
in manhattan so when i'm in school i'll
be living in manhattan but i commute to
kansas city because i work
uh 30 hour shifts uh because i'm a
caretaker so i just work 30 hour shifts
and then go back to manhattan
what do you make at your job at that job
i have another job but i work pr in
there at
the job that i'm speaking to you about i
would make uh
11 an hour okay
okay so so the i guess the first goal
is pay cash for finishing school
yeah and that includes the tuition and
that includes your living expenses
now you've got two sources to do that
that's why i'm asking all these
questions you have the income
that you have coming in and you have the
eight thousand dollars right
yes and through the end of the through
the end of the summer i anticipate i'll
make another thirty five hundred dollars
between the hours i'm working at both
jobs this summer
good so we're looking at about well
what's your budget for the fall then
you need three thousand for tuition and
how much for to finish the fall up
another five thousand
um probably somewhere around there
probably a little less because i don't
spend that much on food or living
expenses outside of rent yeah
okay so that's the 8 000 bucks
and you got 3 500 more so you got a
little bit of pad but you don't have an
extra 15 000 laying around
how much is your car note about nine
thousand dollars
what what's the note a month oh it's
about 225.
okay that's in there too yeah yeah so i
think the car is going to get paid off
after you graduate and you're going to
use the money
from the summer and the money from the
sale of the investments to make sure you
graduate yeah
okay yeah i mean you got it's gonna take
you almost all of that
but i mean you may end up with three or
four thousand dollars laying around
by the time you graduate it sounds like
you're going to i hope you do
um maybe five thousand laying around but
when you graduate and get the full-time
regular job and you settle into
uh an adult process rather than a
college process
then i would reach over and start your
baby steps and actually pay off the car
right now i'm just trying to get you out
of school with that without that what
are
you
are you do you see something different
no no no i i i don't dave that's what i
was asking i knew he had nine thousand i
just want to make sure his monthly bills
wasn't straining him with this 3 000 and
another 5 000 coming
so that's what i was just trying to make
sure but i don't see nothing different
at all the only thing i would add is
you know i i would i'm a little
concerned you know what if something
happens between you and your young lady
and y'all gotta go separately and then
your housing goes up
uh but um i'm i'm agreeing with you dave
yeah
you gotta it sounds like you got a 8 000
plus 3 500 and you need
somewhere around 8 000. so you've got
somewhere around a 4 000
pad give or take the way things are laid
out today
just to get through it's not a bunch of
money but at least you've got a little
bit of wiggle room without debt that's
the main thing i want to get you out
of school with no more debt exactly and
then we can go back and clean up the car
yes later when you actually start with
the adult job and so forth
that's what we call it i guess post
college post college job there we go
that's a good question though our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself
why they are such a wonderful company
that i've endorsed for over a decade
they're the number one online retailer
of custom window coverings with free
samples
free shipping and they always have new
promos be sure you use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal at
blinds.com
let me get the question dave all right
how are you gonna get it from me yeah
okay uh today's question comes from
nicole in pennsylvania she says i'm 32
i'm a 32 year old woman i am currently
in baby step number two i have about 20
000
in debt and will pay that off when i
receive the proceeds from the sale of my
home
i will also put money aside for my fully
funded emergency fund
completing baby step 3. my question is
this dave
after i start putting 15 aside for
retirement should i focus on building
wealth
as a single mom without children
i'm 32 years old i'm currently
babysitting me too sorry
you you read that wrong you can't be a
single mom without children
you wouldn't be a mom should i focus on
building a wealth as a
single woman without children oh a
single woman not a single mom
okay you can't be a mom without kids
okay yeah
it's so confusing all right the uh all
right so
uh yeah
why not i mean the goal here the
the goal of the baby steps is to cause
you to build wealth yeah i don't see
anything else
getting out of debt is so that you have
control of your most powerful wealth
building tool which is your income
yep and all the data that we have says
that if you get out of debt
you are going to become wealthy faster
than if you screw around with that
it's pretty simple yeah it's 30 years of
doing this so
the goal is to build wealth so single
woman single mom
single guy married couple whatever
grandma grandpa little little 19 year
old getting started the goal
is build wealth yeah and you're already
doing that by putting aside
15 percent you know that's how you start
so i want you to
you said after i start putting aside 15
no putting aside 15 is the beginning
process of building wealth
long term yeah and then the next
question is with money you have above
that 15 percent
do you want to just invest even more
or do you want to start saving towards
the house yeah that's the only two
options there in the baby steps but both
of those move you towards wealth
exactly owning a home is going to move
you towards wealth
and as long as you do it properly and it
doesn't become a curse
right yeah uh but the uh but there's no
requirement
that anyone buy a home at any certain
stage somewhere along the line you want
to buy one
yes but right now you're a single lady
making money and you want to just pile
it up and build you up a big old honking
emergen a big ol honking mutual fund
and look over there i got a half million
dollars makes me feel good do it
have at it girl get it get it
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey open
phones at triple eight
eight two five five five now you've
heard me talking about
timeshares for many years
we're going to be doing a another
timeshare show
talking about america's largest
legalized fraud
very soon if you have been a customer
of a time share or
you're currently a timeshare owner
former owner or current owner
we are conducting a new survey where we
want your thoughts and opinions
and your experience with the timeshare
industry
text the word timeshare 233
789 and you can participate in this
research study
text timeshare 233789
also if you want to be a part of the
radio show as we're discussing this
we want to hear your stories about
how you've been screwed over by the
timeshare business
and we want to hear from you if you want
to share your story about
the timeshare business about your
experience with getting trapped in one
of these tiger cages and they say pet
the tiger pet the tiger we'll give you a
free night
we'll give you a free tickets to the
show tickets to the water park
whatever the crap and you get in there
and maybe you've been stuck in one of
these things for years and can't get out
of it
and you've experienced this we want to
hear from you we want to hear your story
we want to give you the opportunity to
tell your story on the air
for 22 million people but we need to
hear from you right now
if you want to be on the air and tell
your story
we need you to email daveonair
ramseysolutions.com dave
on air one word no spaces at
ramseysolutions.com
put time sharing the subject line put a
little bit about your story and how we
can get in touch with you and kelly will
get in touch with you
we're not going to tell you what to say
we're just going to line up the time for
you to call to be able to call you get
you on the air
and make you part of that hour where
we're discussing the timeshare
business we want to hear your story
america needs to hear your story
dave on air at ramseysolutions.com
put time share in the subject line we'll
get back to you sarah's with us in
austin texas hi sarah welcome to the
ramsay show
hey how are you guys great how can we
help
well my husband and i found us a month
ago and i want to thank you guys for
lighting a fire under
us um when i was 18
i was ready to get out of the house and
i applied for colleges
i toured many but my mother told me that
if i didn't go to this certain one
i wouldn't go so that put me in debt
about
46 000. my husband and i he's in a
doctorate program for
physical therapy is about 150 and
that would be our debt i want to break
the legacy of my family i'm the first
woman in
my family to graduate college and i want
to continue growing that legacy with no
debt and just being wealthy
and when it comes down to it i'm just
angry at my mother
and i feel a moral obligation to pay my
student loans but i selfishly
don't feel like it's all on me and i
just need advice
and you probably telling me that i'm
being a selfish brat
i wouldn't say that it's how i feel kind
of
yeah i understand um
what's your household income
right now it would be
we make about 44 000
um a month not forty four thousand forty
four hundred a month
and my husband will be making more he
graduates in december but he's in school
full time right now
okay and he's going to be getting a
degree in what
physical therapy okay so he'll be making
70 or 80 grand
yeah right okay and so you're going to
go from a 50 000
income to 120 000 income and you got 180
000
between you and student loan debt does
your mom have a lot of money
no okay no
so what part of you being mad at her
makes her have
money
because she had money she can't pay this
even if she wanted to right
so here's what we agreed on and maybe
this is why
i'm mostly upset with her is because she
said that she would be
paying off the loans for i guess the
rest of her life
and because i was 18 i didn't even think
about it i was like okay sure yeah
so i got married and so i just didn't
even think about my student loans being
a part of my debt and so i was talking
to her because we're
having to move for his clinicals and
she was basically saying so whenever uh
you know you guys get higher paying jobs
you can
you know start paying off your debt
and she's right it just makes me angry
because i didn't even want to because
she forgot the part where she promised
to pay it
exactly yeah that does make you angry
and
she in her ignorance she given that she
did not go to college she said
she drove you to go to a college that
you really couldn't afford
yeah yeah i mean it was a private
christian
school so it was ridiculously expensive
and let me
and if i heard this thing correctly your
husband is still in school right
and so he has about three months left
right so i'm honestly i'm not even
worried about paying back my mom just
yet
that's not even a consideration she's
not her mom she has a student loan i
mean yeah
so here's my thing i'm focusing on
getting my husband out of school without
racking up any more debt
right that's what i'm gonna focus on but
when they graduate should she go to her
mom to
have her mom pay for this uh if her mom
said yes i'm going to talk to my dad and
my parents like hey listen
this is what we're we agreed upon you
know um
don't change now because you know i've
been able to
uh up my income i'm having a serious
respectful but firm conversation
this is not what we it's not what we
agreed to do uh but yes
i'm i'm having a conversation but
outside of that
if she says no dave she's i mean you're
gonna have to pay for it
yeah i would be prepared to pay for it
how old are you
i just turned 25. okay
um
i kind of think i'm hearing between the
sentences
that this behavior
of inconsistency with your mom is a
pattern more than just a singular event
oh yeah oh yeah so it's kind of like
it's kind of like that part of it's kind
of like that part of growing up where
you look over and you realize
my mom's really not right on some of
these things
you know that part of that part of where
you grow up and you realize my parents
really
are not yeah and then you go okay i'm
going to let them be parents anyway i'm
still going to forgive them and move on
i i don't think your mom has 40 000 so i
don't think the discussion matters much
except it just hurts your feelings
yeah i'm afraid you're right yeah i'm
not saying you're a brat i think you
have a valid reason she made you a
promise that she didn't keep
right and led you astray
uh because but it wasn't out of malice
she didn't
you know let's run my daughter deeply in
debt and run her life she didn't that
was not her goal
her goal was she did the best she could
do recommending that
school because she had never been to
school and she thought that was the best
way to do it
right so her she was an enthusiastic
ignoramus
yeah but i mean she was not was not
malice she certainly didn't set out to
hurt you agreed
right for sure yeah she just she just
didn't know what she was doing because
you're first generation college
and that's that's where we run into the
most student loan debt anthony i've
talked about this a lot
it's both uh it's socio-economic but
it's uh it's
regional it's racial it's a lot of
things we see it in all the demographics
when we study the student loan stuff
but it's any time regardless of what
area of the country
your biggest mistakes in what the field
of study is and where you go to school
and how much student loan debt you go
into
are the parents trying to go i didn't
get an education you got to get one i
have no idea how to do it
but education's everything and everybody
goes and overspends
for the wrong thing and that this first
generation college
does it the worst that's the ones that
get screwed over the most
and uh so that's where you are you kind
of fit in that thing
huh i i think the best route
for where do you end up with the best
life for you
at 30 i don't think she can pay it
i don't think you holding her to it is
going to cause anything to change in her
yeah and so probably just a good
relationship with your mom
and call it and just go this sucks and
i'm going to pay it
i'm going to get rid of it i don't think
i'm going to bother her with it because
i don't think she can pay it
and i don't think she set out to harm
you at all
she just didn't know what the flip she
was doing and so
and she's a little ditzy and a little
bit doesn't follow through and that's
aggravating and i get that
but i just let her be mom and move on
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
180 000 in student loan the last
student loans the last lady had with her
husband she had
40 and he had 140 or she had 30 and 150
whatever it was and it's just a
pile of money um if you haven't checked
out
the i mean the student loan crisis is a
it's an of epic proportions the
stupidity
has gone into the stratosphere with this
thing
uh we did a podcast series on it called
borrowed future that
millions of people have downloaded and
listened to
and uh anthony is a tip of the spear on
that thing put it all together with our
team
and uh if you haven't un if you haven't
listened to it uncovering the student
loan crisis
uh it's obviously free and you need to
listen to the
borrowed future podcast um
a little teaser there might be something
in the works a little further on
borrowed future
coming soon to some screens near you
we'll uh
we'll let you know more later but uh
i've gotten to do some of the previews
on it and it's
uh our i am so impressed with our team
yes i am too they made me look real good
dave they did they made you look really
eat i mean you you're smart but they
made you even look smarter than you
absolutely
you uh the bit with uh well anyway
yeah you can get you can get a lot of
the information on the current podcast
and then we're gonna get you some more
soon
in a new format and uh what i was
telling her
a minute ago i think it's worth you and
i unpacking for a minute because we've
talked about it on
on air and off both um
when you started digging into the
student loan crisis and our team started
really
doing the research into it and started
breaking it down
um you know we see people
that pay too much yes pick their own
school
they pick the wrong school they pick a
degree that has no profit
that has no uh career possibilities
equal to what they paid meaning there's
no roi no return on investment on this
level of education uh and so
you know if you can become a high school
math teacher
uh for uh you know twelve thousand
dollars a year at your local state
school tuition which is what the state
schools
average right now um or you can spend
fifty thousand dollars a year
for exactly the same job uh and if you
were gonna go into that we'd say it's
two hundred thousand
versus uh forty thousand yes
yes uh we're not gonna tell you go into
that but when you just compare those two
things right there
for the for for the exact same career
field right
uh it's asinine it's definitely what
people have been led to do
chosen to do yeah dave and another thing
that we've i've learned is people
are and mercedes respectfully they're
lazy
they don't want to step back and do
their research and see what are the
programs and the opportunities out there
you're talking about forty thousand
let's go even a little bit deeper dave
if you go to like one of the schools
let's say unc wilmington unc
pembroke you can actually if you get
accepted into the school
you you will only pay five hundred
dollars up in one of their programs
a semester that's a thousand dollars a
year four thousand dollars
for a bachelor's degree to become a
school teacher yeah but people do not
want to step
back and do the research know what they
want to do if they're in north carolina
they want to go to chapel hill they want
to go to duke they want to go to these
big names which is nothing wrong with it
but they think
if i go to duke i'll be a better school
teacher than going to unc pembroke no
no not not no you know you're getting
the same education going to the same
school
getting paid the same money but you paid
10 times more than actually stepping
back and doing the
research and picking the right school
that's going to elevate you
give you the education which is
important but what is your long-term
gain
yeah so here's the warning for you guys
out there
um if you're whether you're the student
that's watching us maybe on youtube and
you're thinking of going into college
in the future you're 17 18 16 19
whatever in that age group or whether
you're the parent
the thing that anthony and i have seen
where the largest
mistakes happen
i mentioned to her earlier it was her
mom
didn't know anything about higher
education facts
yeah yeah because she hadn't gone to
college and there's no shame in that
but it's like buying a car and you've
never owned one yeah
and you go well you know you need to get
a bentley
you know you ought to get a mercedes
because i heard they're really good
but i've never owned a car i've never
even driven a car
that's a good that's an example and so
but you know but i heard they're really
good yeah
i heard those mercedes are really good
cars yeah well i ain't gain money
but i'm gonna go sign up for chevrolet
because my mom i mean i'm gonna go sign
up for a a
bentley or a mercedes instead of a
chevrolet because my mom or dad
has never been there so mom and dad if
you even if you didn't go to school
there is zero shame in that as a matter
of fact it might just be
awesome that you didn't go to school i'm
you're not in debt life is good right
but if your kid is getting ready to go
to school
get some people in your corner
that have uh that have a have a
four-year degree
that i have made some of the mistakes
maybe
uh that aren't thinking like society is
thinking like our broken culture is
thinking
because otherwise you could really screw
up your kid
yeah yeah by allowing by two things one
is allowing them to pay too much and two
is allowing them to study
um left-wing feminism or something and
then all of a sudden you've got no
ability to get a job because there's no
such thing as a job for that yeah
and you can you can study it if you want
to study it but
uh whatever the thing is left-handed
puppetry
bb stacking i don't know what everything
is we want to make fun of
that is a useless freaking degree and
then you pay
200 000 bucks in debt to get a useless
freaking degree
this most often happens in first
generation where the
college yes where their parents did not
go to school when you and i first
started looking at this
we we had the hypothesis that uh that it
was more racial
because you were seeing a lot of people
in the black community yes that were
having this exact problem
exactly and you kept going this is my my
people and this is a problem and i kept
going is it is it really a racial thing
and because and then we dove into the
numbers and we went yeah
but black people whose parents went to
school yeah went to college
aren't making that mistake it turns out
it's not a it's not a racial thing at
all it's
it's it's a it's mostly the data tells
us as we've studied this and researched
it
that regardless of your skin color yep
uh it is
your propensity to do something really
really damaging to yourself
because your parents didn't know how to
guide you through it absolutely
and give you bad advice here's the thing
what i'm learning about the second
generation dave
is the first generation parent goes to
school and then the parent says all
right i want you to go to my school
because if you go to my school you'll
get better network you'll get a better
network to go get your dream job so then
you go to your parents school
to and rack up all this debt just so i
can meet dave ramsey
and hopefully dave ramsey can connect me
to another
place to get a job which i think that is
completely false as well now networking
is important
yeah but you if you you don't need to go
you don't need to spend uh
50 000 bucks to get a network no that's
that's not that's ridiculous so
the the thing is this so i'm second
generation my my mom and dad did not go
to college
okay so i mean i'm first generation my
kids are second generation right
they went to my school yeah but i did
not send them there for the network
right
i didn't even send them there because i
was romantically involved with the
school like i love the university of
tennessee
and you didn't make them go there yeah i
did
[Laughter]
um i didn't know that absolutely that's
good to know
um i told them they had to go to an
in-state school yeah so
that's that's like the choice i mean it
was
mtsu middle tennessee state university
east tennessee state university or the
university of tennessee and neither
pretty well at
the university of tennessee knoxville
university tennessee chattanooga right
memphis state right i mean these are
your schools you're going to go to
in-state tuition because i'm not going
to pay out-of-state tuition
and if you and and i do not
find any piece of data that says where
you went to school is correlated with
your success
okay i can't find that anywhere
absolutely education is important where
you got it turns out there's not a
single piece of research
right that says you're more successful
if you went to harvard right you can't
find it okay
it's it's mythology yeah and seth godin
calls it
in a borrowed future he's he doesn't
call them um
prestigious schools he calls them famous
schools yeah that's it
they become famous any school kids are
not necessarily better they're just
famous right oh my kid went to such a
citizen
and and and you paid how much to be able
to make that's one stupid sentence
yeah man oh my god it's unbelievable we
gotta tell dave offline though you made
your kids go to a school i made them go
to an in-state school and i paid
i was paying for it so i get the right
to decide where you're going
that's right i give you i have this
weird thing i think i'm in charge
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
debt-free degree
is my co-host open phones here as we
talk about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
mike starts off this hour in dallas
texas hey mike how are you
i am doing good thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so my question is um my wife and i
just finished baby step three and so
in looking into my retirement
account at work i have a 401k and i
discovered that i can
either do it as pre-tax or a roth
and so i was wanting to find out is
there
a difference between a roth 401k
versus the roth ira and
which is you know the better should i do
both
or just one that's a good question is
there a max uh i'm not a max
a match with your rod 401k
uh yes my work matches six percent
yeah so what we teach here is it's
always gonna be match
roth than traditional so i'm going with
your matched
roth 401k before a roth ira
but that's because of the match because
of the roth they're both roths meaning
they both will grow without
taxes on the growth so a roth i.r.a
grows exactly like a roth 401k
obviously the 401k has a handful of
options and the ira has
8 000 mutual funds you can choose from
that would be your main difference but
uh if your 401k has
good strong mutual fund options uh
you certainly do the match first what
anthony was saying
but then beyond that if you want to say
do i continue there in the roth
401k unmatched portion or do i do a
personal roth
it won't matter if you picked exactly
the same mutual funds you'd have exactly
the same results
so if you've got good funds in your 401k
which most do these days uh then you're
fine to just use your 401k to get to
your 15
in baby step four okay
that makes sense to you yeah it's yes
yeah and it's got
some it's with one of the big firms and
it's got some pretty good
um pretty good options in there for me
yeah it makes it real simple to not have
to do the personal one but
now what's your household income
uh right around 115 a year okay
so you can get to uh you can get to 15
of your household income within your
401k
yes yeah and uh without maxing it out or
anything so you don't have to do the
personal
and as long as you got good options i
would just do that from a simplicity
standpoint
easy just makes it real easy you don't
think about it it's autopilot it's
coming out your check
you know life goes on good question
brittany's in connecticut hey brittany
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave it's nice to talk to you guys
today you too how can we i just have
um i have a fairly general question but
with like
intricate details i guess um my question
more or less is what more can
i do um my husband and i on baby step
two we actually bought a house in march
and then started your program
um and in april he left for a six-month
training
in virginia um so we're putting
everything extra that we can towards
our guests who've paid off about
seventeen thousand so far
um he does and he does full time down
there so he gets like a podium and
everything
um i work two part-time jobs adding up
to about fifteen dollars an hour and i
run a
very small business out of our home and
i have a i take care of a two-year-old
at home
um and i just don't know what more i can
do to help towards it
um i feel like he's doing so much and
he's away
um i get to see him once or twice a
month at the
at the moment but um just any advice on
what more we can do i guess so brittany
how much what's your total amount of
debt
uh total was twenty five thousand we
paid about
13 off so far that's your seventh one
since when since a
march end of march y'all are grinding we
phone
everything we can um well at that rate
at that rate you'll be done in three
months yeah
the whole thing um well no i'm talking
about mathematically
it's not hoping oh yeah well we had like
the um anything we got back from
uh taxes and stuff so how much are you
paying on the debt a month
about three thousand oh three thousand
you're not gonna be done in three months
yeah okay
yeah no hopefully more like more like
eight months okay
yeah but if we like anything extra he
makes throwing door dash
or i make with my little side stuff and
we try to sew towards it
so let me let me say this on an
encouraging celebrity because i hear the
passion in your heart like
i want to help more i want to help more
this is what we teach here at ramsay is
be intentional
get a plan live below your means and
throw everything
at it and if you're doing those four
things which it sounds like we could
dive a little bit deeper to see what
else you could do
but i really want you to hear this and
even everyone listening as well
that once you're doing all those four
things the next step from there is just
keep that going and be patient
throughout this journey
putting three thousand dollars towards
this debt you all are already doing
great you've knocked out 13
13 or 17 whichever one uh that that you
did
um that that's phenomenal i mean that's
phenomenal
people who make more money than you call
into the show and don't knock out that
much money
within that amount of time so i want you
to hear that what you and your husband
doing right now
is great you know but can we add some
more
we can dive into some numbers and see
that there but i just wanted to start
off this this conversation by hey
you're doing a great job thus far uh but
let's see what else we can do
yeah the you got the hustle part now you
got next step is the grind part
and you're feeling you're feeling the
grind because this is hard
we're just trying we look forward to the
day we can come to our debt-free stream
but i mean you guys are working like
animals yeah you're not spending a dime
you're completely game on you're as
gazelle intense as you can be
it's hard what you're doing is hard and
it is a grind that's why they call it
hustle and grind right i mean it's
it's hard so i'm with anthony i think
you're doing a really really good job
and i think in the seven or eight months
you're going to be done
so all you're looking for all the time
there's no magic
wand there's no magic pill you're just
looking for where can i cut expenses
where can i increase income where can i
cut expenses where can i increase income
and every time you do that by five
dollars one direction or the other that
five dollars
is going to increase the speed at which
you get out of debt
and now that you've stopped the stupid
and now that you've pointed yourself at
a plan and now that you're submitted to
that plan and you're wide open on that
plan
you're going to get there you are on
your way you're going to get there
and you're probably going to be there by
christmas of this year
you may not quite make it but i think
you might i think you might be done by
christmas
can you be standing out in the front
yard yelling merry christmas
people be going that woman lost her mind
no she's debt free baby
exactly she's been hustling she's been
grinding she hadn't lost her mind at all
the rest of you people have lost your
minds this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how many of you guys are stressed out or
you're hurting because you took a major
hit during covet of last year
you're worried maybe about your
investments your retirement
maybe you're wondering what it's going
to take to catch up
maybe you lost some ground maybe you got
out at exactly the wrong time maybe you
got in
exactly the right time i don't know but
if you pulled everything out and now
you're wondering where you should go
from here listen
if you're in one of these situations i
want you to know you don't have to face
the pain
the uncertainty alone you can sit down
with a conscientious
investment pro like one of our smart
vester pros
they're not going to tell you to invest
in something dumb like gold
they're going to tell you to spend a ton
of time looking at your current they're
going to spend a ton time looking at
your current situation help you create a
plan
to get you where you want to go you
don't have to let 2020 kill your
confidence
go to ramseysolutions.com smart vester
to find an investment pro in your area
ramsay solutions dot com
slash smart vester
i'm dave ramsey your host anthony o'neil
ramsey personality is
my co-host today carol is with us in
phoenix
hi carol how are you hi i'm good how are
you
better than i deserve what's up so
i'm paying my son's um student loans
which is my choice my parents paid for
my college so
i just feel i should pay for his so it's
my choice and i'm willing to do that
i only have fifty six hundred dollars
left however the company that he works
for
pays a hundred dollars a month towards
his student loans as well
so my question is should i just pay it
off and be done with it
or should i continue to let them pay a
hundred dollars a month
towards the student loans can you do
both
i mean because a hundred dollars a month
that's twelve hundred dollars a year
that's four years like can you go ahead
and just
pay it off yourself and just take the
hundred dollars extra as well as you're
paying it off
i can i can do that um i mean like i
said i could pay it all off right now or
oh you have the money to pay it off
today
the whole thing all right then you would
then you would miss the benefit i see
so two little days on each shoulder
one good one saying you know pay it off
what is your how much money do you have
what's your net
um total probably about
um almost 900 000.
well the way i answer questions on this
show is if i woke up in your shoes what
would i do
okay so you're a millionaire way to go
and do you worry about five thousand
dollars no you don't
you wanted to pay for his education you
write a check and you pay for it don't
worry about it
okay it's not okay if it was if it was a
fifty thousand dollar swing
in out of nine hundred it might get my
attention
it's half of a percent
of your world one half of one percent
of your whole financial world right
right it's it's irrelevant yeah yeah and
so
uh you know it's not again if it was 50
grand we might say
okay take the benefit set the money
aside
and then when the benefit pays it all
off then you can release that money
but um i'm just not gonna screw with it
for five grand in your situation i'm
gonna be done with it write a check be
done with it clear it yeah that's five
years too that's that's my scary part
yeah will my son be and is he still
going to even be working there
and we're screwing around with all this
for a hundred dollars exactly it's just
um it's not worth the effort
that's not even covering the interest
yeah that's that's yeah good question
uh cindy's in chicago hi cindy how are
you
i'm good thanks how are you today better
than i deserve how can we help
well i have a bit of a housing question
i am and i'll try to be as
succinct as i can i'm 60 years old have
been retired for three years
just got called in from an old boss
that wants me to come back into the
workforce probably
about 150k a year
but the position is six hours
away from here so
do i rent a house do i
am i insane to even think about it are
you married
yes yes we have well he's good to go i
mean he's
yeah so it'd be both of you going this
is like an adventure
yeah it could be an adventure but i
don't really want to in this market
i'm kind of scared to buy a house for
two to three years
yeah oh i agree um so
um and i don't really want to do it now
oh i might
so why where where would you be living
columbus ohio okay when this and how
long would this gig last do you think
um he wants it's a startup business and
i love building things starting things
so i mean he's i told him i'm not going
to be there 10 years because i'll be 70.
so that ain't happening but i would do
maybe two to five okay let's call it
five
near 65. uh and the the gig is up
and uh you made uh 600 grand
and my husband's 72 okay is that where
you want to spend the next five years in
columbus ohio
yeah i don't know i oh i am i need to go
there yet and where do you
and after that's over where do you want
to be living
i doesn't matter i don't have any okay
so i think what i want to do is i want
to aim at where you want to be living 10
years from now and that might answer
your question
or seven years from now okay we want to
be living in florida
i'm just making this up okay yeah well
you sell the property in chicago you
move to columbus you rent until you get
this gig done
and then you move to florida and you buy
your retirement place
okay so that rent would be uh yeah but
if you're going to stay
in columbus after the gig is over
because you just love columbus
and you want you know we want to watch
the sunset there in the end of our life
then that's cool go ahead and start
talking about making a purchase there
okay like like at least the first year
so just hang out and rent
yeah nothing wrong with that at all okay
what a cool thing
it's kind of fun it's kind of fun to
feel that valuable right i was just
sitting on my desk
having a glass of wine enjoy my night
and never happened yeah
you know what i think i'd ask for more
just see if he'd give it
okay i think i will
[Laughter]
just because you know because this is
all just for fun anyway right
yeah what do i get to lose right yeah i
mean like
i can go back on the deck with another
glass of wine if you don't bring the
price up
exactly thanks to you we're 1.6 million
so and that's
all tribute to you so i didn't do i
didn't give you any money you did it all
i'm proud of you though way to go
so how much of that did you inherit yeah
there's another one another everyday
millionaire right there another one
right there and you know what i like
about that
and i get a ton of stupid i
i got to inspire myself i love it i love
it
and here's one thing i love about your
your story um is
you you're debt free 1.6 million you
have options
so if if if this doesn't work out you're
okay
like you don't need this you're doing
this because you want
it's just kind of for fun yeah yeah it's
like what do i got to lose right
you're going to make 150 000 yeah you
you trade chicago for columbus for a
little while yeah
not a big deal do this and she goes to
two million in the next five years oh
more
yeah much more come on yeah you're gonna
be at five
yeah it's pretty incredible so what was
your what were your
careers when you were working and
building this wealth
um physical therapy and i ran a clinical
research team
okay all right medicine and
so you had a household income a couple
hundred
yeah back then yeah at the end yeah
i mean yeah in the uh the 1.6
is what mutual funds mutual funds and
house
house what's the house worth yeah
300. okay oh all right so majority
that's in mutual a way to go
and you inherited how much of the total
1.6
yeah zero i think i asked that a minute
ago okay
i just like i like asking it over and
over again just to remind all these
left-wing idiots out there that all rich
people didn't inherit their money
you know as a matter of fact most of
them didn't oh there you go
most of them are cindy way to go cindy
what a cool place you are in so proud of
you
[Music]
i bet he pays her 200 to come what do
you all bet
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five julian is with us in
jacksonville florida hi julian how are
you
[Music]
i'm doing better than i deserve dave
good how can we help today
so i had a question for you i wanted to
ask you if i should start a business
right now at this point in my life
why not so i'm currently 22
i'm about to graduate college in about
two semesters
and i was very fortunate to have
uh worked when i was in high school at
one point i was doing almost 30 hours a
week while in high school
and through a very aggressive portfolio
i've managed to
end up buying a house at this point so i
currently have
a house that i bought and i'm moving
into it in august at this point
what are you studying so i studied
computer
science okay so i'm an engineer for
computer science
and um what's the business you're going
to start while you're in school
so i was we were going to start an
electric mobility
business for personal transportation so
this would be arranging everything from
electric mobility for older uh people
and as well as small personal
transportation like electric scooters
and skateboards
sounds interesting he said we you and
some friends
uh so all so the ideas and all the
designs are mine
uh i have a few friends that i'm
considering bringing on
i haven't decided 100 on that yet
okay
okay so you're going to design for
instance a scooter
have it manufactured and sell it correct
so it'd be small-scale manufacturing um
some of the initial market research i've
done as well as
i have my uh i have all the supplies and
everything already set and ready and
based on that it makes
it makes economical sense to do it so
walk me through that part what are you
selling them for what's the total
dollars involved
uh so we're we're aiming to have about
three different models
ranging from a 500 people this is for
electric scooter parks at least
ranging from 500 to about 1200 uh for
the 500 we're looking at about
250 dollars manufacturing and selling
for 500
and for the upper end for the 1200 one
we're looking at about six hundred
dollars to manufacture
and the twelve hundred dollars to sell
all right and that line's about
that's about lined up with what the
current market and what wholesale value
and how many would you do in your first
run
i'm sorry how many would you make in
your first run
um so we were gonna sell locally first
uh and we were gonna do about uh a
hundred of each model
six hundred thousand dollars that's
correct
and where's this money coming from
uh i was very fortunate to have been
investing money in the stock market
um and i just ended up with
quite a bit of money and how much that's
kind of where i am right now
how much man so so right now
uh including so i just bought the house
so i'm sitting on about uh around 400.
do you pay cash for the home i did pay
cash for the house correct
so the 400 including the house and as
well as all the taxes for the capital
gains have been paid off
no i would not start this business
no i would not start this business
here's why here's the rule of thumb that
i use
anytime you have to james bond the deal
you don't do the deal james bond in
every movie is playing cards with the
villain and puts all his chips on the
table for one hand
if he loses that hand the world gets
collapsed
and we all die if you put four hundred
thousand dollars there
only four hundred thousand dollars into
scooters and they don't sell
you're screwed you're back to zero
no i would not bet the farm on one hand
that's bad diversification it's bad
economics it's bad business practices
you would need to start much smaller
than you're talking about starting
and prove your concept somewhere other
than
in your dreams so are you saying
i started or just start small i'm saying
start uber
uber small very very small not with uber
i agree but start
like one tenth of what you're talking
about if you want to put 60 grand of
your 400 in
and go sell those and then use that
money to buy the next batch and that
money to buy the next batch fine
am i dropping 600 in when i've only got
400 and this thing turns sideways and
you end up with zero and a bunch of
scooters in your garage
no thank you
and julian he's only teaching what i've
i've watched him do
the man has moved yeah here's what
here's what happens man
because i i am i've been doing this
running this business for almost 30
years
yeah we made almost all of our money
julian off of 10 of our ideas the other
90
of our ideas sucked
every entrepreneur experiences that you
guys in the public never see
most of you never see the 90 of our
ideas this sucked
but if we had scaled them all to use up
our entire net worth
on one of those ideas that sucked we
would have been out of business
instead you do you run test markets and
you prove you do social proofing on this
somewhere other than your research of
the marketplace you
actually go sell something because
people when they're taking surveys and
they say oh yes i would buy that
they lie until you ask them for their
freaking money and then when they give
you real money
and there's a transaction that occurs
that is market research dude
that will get you there so no i do if
the only way to do this
is for you to spend all of the money
that you have
on this one play only to find out that
you're late to the scooter game that
bird already beat you there
only to find out that electronic skate
boards are now out of business because
everybody keeps cracking their head open
and nobody wants to ride them anymore
only to find out the things that are
happening in the consumer marketplace
that you couldn't see
with your research lens and then you
lose it all
because you bet the farm on one horse
race
and you lose the family farm no that is
a lack of a diversification that's james
bonding it
and i teach small business people this
all the time in entre leadership if you
got to slide all your chips to the
middle of the table
and that one that one hand of cards then
you're making a bad play
that only works in the movies that only
works in some book that some guy wrote
where he forgot to tell you about all
the fish he didn't catch
before he caught the big one because the
truth is in the real world
90 of our ideas suck the truth is
there's three rules of business
it takes twice as long as you think it's
going to it costs twice as much as you
think it's going to and you're not the
exception those are the three rules of
business
and i man i've experienced that i
knocked all the hair off my head dude
and i i don't want you to have to
experience it the wrong way yeah
one of the reasons i went broke in the
real estate business is i had all of my
chips
into on the table in one business model
that was broken yeah and when the
business model when the cracks in the
business model happened and the business
model
you know crashed in on my head yeah i
didn't have anything left it broke me
and it's a lack of diversification it's
a bad it's bad business process
yeah so don't do it but i like the way
you've outlined it i like the way he's
thinking though dave as far as and i
want to be
i never met a 20 year old that ran up
400 000 bucks in the stock market
exactly i'm curious about that too but
yeah but you know just assuming
this you know it's 100 here's the
problem jillian
you're you are unbelievably smart
and that might be your biggest handicap
that's true
you're gonna overthink crap and you're
gonna you you're gonna have an
intellectual arrogance that because
you're so stinking smart
that's gonna cause you to step in dog
poo and you're never gonna see it coming
because you you were looking and i'm
telling you some of us are a little
dumber we got an advantage
because you you obviously been 20 years
old you're you're a
freaking savant man doing what you're
doing it's awesome i'm so proud of you
pay cash
but do not bet the farm on this you you
i don't know what you did right they got
you to 400 but it got you there
and i'm happy for you that you got it
but now
from there what i would do is use
standard business acumen
and let's test market this let's pilot
it
it with a tenth of what you're talking
about where if you lose 60 grand
and instead of 400 you got 340 i'm not
so pissed
you lose this whole thing because bird
comes along and eats your lunch with a
scooter world or something
i just don't i don't want you to do that
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today colossians 3 12 is
god's
chosen people holy and dearly loved
clothe yourselves
with compassion kindness humility
gentleness and patience
richard branson said i've always
believed that the way you treat your
employees is the way they will treat
your customers
and the people flourish when they are
praised
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're answering your
questions about life kiernan is with us
in san antonio hi karen how are you
hi i'm doing great how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up
hey i'm 28 years old i make about 63
grand a year
i got a bachelor's in economics a
master's in public administration
got about 130 in student loan debt
i got about 50 sitting in an investment
account
six dashed away and uh in a traditional
ira in iraq the roth has got a grand in
it the traditional
got five in it my employer puts 10
percent of my salary
in a 401k for me uh
job is in dc live in texas
because of the covid thing at some point
i'm going to have to go back to
dc was in the peace corps for three
years i'm 30
payments into the student loan
forgiveness
portion of the 120 that i've got to make
to to get the balance for given at the
end of
that uh cheaper for me to
buy something in dc a condo looks like
because that's to me about what i could
afford
what's your question uh how do well how
do i untangle all of this
it's easy pay off the debt yeah we need
to get rid of student loan debt here's
the thing
to date the 120 month
due to serving a non-profit student loan
forgiveness program
uh the pslf the public service
loan forgiveness program has had
250 000 people apply
after they finish their 120 payments
they have granted 3700
out of 250 000 it's a scam
wow it's not something you want to bank
on
uh the government has lied and uh
they're not
following through on it there are some
types of student loan forgiveness that
actually do work
that one does not work uh the data on it
is horrendous and heartbreaking because
people spent
10 freaking years working towards it and
uh so you currently work for the peace
corps
no no no no i i work for a
uh an agency of the federal government
okay so that's why you only make 60 000
when you have a master's degree
in public policy
because you should be making double that
right
um i i suppose having spent three years
in africa and
i'm not not looking for
uh for anything stateside yeah
i don't know honestly i mean you're you
had a
a degree in economics right and a
master's in public
what was it administration public
administration administration
yeah um and
i mean generally that does line you up
for a governmental position without a
doubt
but um yeah i i i think you probably are
worth more than you're paid
in the marketplace um i was a little
shocked when i heard that
the masters and i heard that 60k so
anyway
the way i untangle it is i work on the
career side of this equation say am i
really being paid what
i am worth in this marketplace and make
sure that you're worth that i could be
wrong
uh i'm not 100 sure and then i'm going
to get about the business of getting the
student loan cleaned up
so that i can begin investing so right
back to anthony's point
clearing the debt is the simple uh
and the correct mathematical way to get
you the closest way to
some kind of uh financial peace some
kind of financial stability some level
of wealth
uh the shortest distance between there
you and there is to clean
clear this student loan debt and you
know here's a problem that i have with
this program dave and correct me if i'm
wrong but it's like a lot of these
people see this well i'm gonna make the
minimum payment when they have the means
to make
a lot more when they have the means to
pay it off some of them do
but they say you know what just make the
minimum living this for 10 years
and see if they forgive me then they get
to the end they won't forgive me now
they got to go another two three years
to pay it off
yeah it's clear yeah and it's yeah aside
from the fact that it's just
misleading exactly hundreds of thousands
of people that have not been able
to get the government to do what they
thought they were promised
and uh some cases they haven't followed
through on the details in some cases
uh something else is going on but it's
the
it's the ugliest one of the ugliest
stories in the whole student loan
debacle
so um i mean well yeah i i'm not going
to wait on
someone else to fix this if i'm in your
shoes i'm going to work on the income
side of my equation
and i'm going to clear the student loan
debt so that i can get about the
business of building wealth
and i would stop adding to investments
until you get this mess cleaned up
uh but i really do think you can double
your income i
might be wrong i'm wrong a lot of times
but i
he can get it you've got i think you've
got some legitimate education that's
usable in the marketplace there
yes sir i really do uh nicholas is with
us in san francisco hi nicholas how are
you
hi hi dave how can we help
so i'm 20 27 years old and single i have
no debt
i have a hundred thousand dollars in
savings and i make 250
a year and before the pandemic i was
kind of
living well beyond my means however post
pandemic
something changed and i started just
spending basically all my income
i don't know like something during the
pandemic made me change my outlook
invite
i don't know if this new way of life is
the correct way
or should i go back on being super
frugal
and go on and saving all my income
does my question make sense yeah so
you're saying that the
post pandemic you start spending
everything you make
exactly just like i don't know
does that indicate what i think it
indicates i think it indicates you're
hopeless
you don't believe in the future anymore
so spend it all now because the future
is not going to be there
i guess i don't know it's like a yellow
mentality like you only live once
yeah like before before the pandemic i
will just say that
but yo yolo takes on two forms yolo
takes on the form of i
i don't believe there is a positive
future which is hopelessness
and the other type of yolo is just
simple immaturity
and it's i'm a child and i want to go
thank god it's friday oh god it's monday
and i have no discipline whatsoever
and i'm just want to be immature and
spin my butt off
and i don't care i'm hedonistic i don't
care anything about
any noble calling in this life at all
that's the general yolo falling but
occasionally i run into a yolo that's
based in hopelessness hope deferred
makes the heart sick
the proverb says but when desire comes
it is the tree of life
and so i think your heart got broken oh
yeah
yeah yeah 26 year old though dave tend
to believe that
i'm young you only live once enjoy it
yeah but he was he was a saver before
but changed him exactly he didn't
suddenly become immature
right pandemic didn't make him immature
not at all
so i'm going to tell you nicholas i
think that you sit down and you think
about
do i really believe that this is all
going to work if i play it through you
you quit believing it was going to work
if i save money yeah if i save and
invest i don't want you to be
necessarily make 250 000 a year you
don't need to live on beans and rice
okay but you do need to be saving money
and that's a a spiritual emotional
psychological indicator that you believe
in the future
and if you quit believing in the future
because of the pandemic that's
hopelessness and i that's what i smell
right and i wouldn't quit believing in
the future if you had a hundred thousand
dollars saved it got you through the
pandemic so that should have been proof
that
your philosophy was working yeah yeah
i can promise you this about the future
there's gonna be awesome times
i can also promise you this about the
future there's gonna be bad times yes
sir
count on it and be ready for both be the
pig in the brick house the third pig the
third one
where when the wolf comes he huffs any
puffs
and you're in the brick house and that's
enjoying your life and saving money
both it's not just one or the other hope
that helps
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you